so as followers of Christ believing in
him as our personal Lord and Savior how
does that how does the Judgment go for
believe followers of Christ as their
personal Lord and Savior compared to
people you are judge for your rewards
and ranks so disci discipleship in a way
uh well I don't know what you mean
disciple I mean you have to be disciple
means you'll be judged for your
obedience and lack
thereof because your judgment is one of
ranks and rewards if you are a Believer
United Christ unbelievers they're given
a life riew to show why they deserve the
Judgment that God want to leash on them
so Believers unbelievers all stand
before the same judgment seat and yet
Believers judgment because they're
believers they know they're with the
Lord It's to determine their ranks and
positions their Rewards or lack thereof
unbelievers they'll be shown all their
evil deeds and why they deserve the
Wrath to come because they didn't accept
their the provision of Salvation amen
understood thank you for that because
the Bible does talk about I mean if you
have a Bible I'll show you where it
talks about some will be great in heaven
some will be least in Heaven I got it
right in front of me if you don't mind
go to Matthew
5:19 therefore whoever relaxes one of
the least of these Commandments and
teaches others to do the same will be
called the least in the Kingdom of
Heaven uh will be the called the least
in the Kingdom of Heaven
so there ranks in
heaven to my understanding of this the
context of this passage yes and then
read the next part because he going to
see it but whoever does them and teaches
them will be called great in the Kingdom
of Heaven so you mean there's some who
be great and some will who be
least so and how do you become great
what do you must do is it one of the
least of these Commandments and teaches
others to do the same will be called the
least in the Kingdom of Heaven but
whoever does them and teaches them will
be called in the Kingdom of Heaven so to
do the teaches to do follow the
Commandments and to teach them yes so in
other words when I stand before the Lord
and I am a believer and United to Christ
the Lord's going to show me my life and
where I succeeded and where I failed in
obeying his commands and that will
determine my position and rank that's
what he says right yes sir and if you're
one of those Christians who are coasting
along your rank will be very low in the
Kingdom
now let me give you other verses go to
Matthew
1111 truly I say to you among those born
of woman there has arisen no one greater
than John the Baptist yet the one who is
least in the Kingdom of Heaven is
greater than he so the least will be
greater in rank than John but then there
are those who are greater than the least
one in the Kingdom right wow that's
profound okay now you ready I'm GNA give
you some more Matthew 20
you're going to read 23 to 28 it's
actually 2428 but I want you to pick it
up in 23 20 23 to 28 he said to them you
will drink my cup but to sit at my right
hand and at my left hand I'm sorry to
sit at my right hand and at my left is
not mine to Grant but it is for those
for whom it has been prepared by my
father so notice right hand and left
hand are the highest positions next to
the
king they want to be the highest ranking
in the Kingdom next to Jesus the king
they want to be on his right and his
left he goes that's been assigned by my
father now keep
reading and when the 10 heard they were
Indigent at the two brothers but Jesus
called them to him and said you know
that the rulers of the Gentiles Lord it
over them and their great ones exercise
authority over them it shall not be so
among you but whoever let me explain
what he's saying the rulers of the world
they exercise their power by subjugating
people to them right by subjugating you
right humiliating you and controlling
you that's how they rule not you you who
want to be in my kingdom that's not how
you become great so how do you become
great in Jesus's Kingdom it shall not be
so among you but whoever would be great
among you must be your servant and
whoever would be first among you must be
your slave even as the son of man came
not to be served but to serve and to
give his life as a r for many amen so
you want to be great then become the
least on Earth you want to be high
ranking serve on Earth don't cause
people to serve you you serve because I
the king have come to serve right that's
a great point there are ranks and
rewards right and that kind of cross
references to Philippians 2:5 to1 how be
he took on the form of a serve a yeah
you see you made the connection God
bless you and the Holy Spirit fill you
with Insight amen he came to be a
servant to serve and what did the father
do in light of Jesus willfully humbling
himself exalted him the difference is
the exaltation he's now a man too before
that he wasn't a man he was Spirit
right har pman I remember you saying
that in the video yes but remember this
though he's Spirit right when he came
down because God is Spirit by Nature he
didn't have flesh right now do me a
favor go to 1 Corinthians 3 11-5 here is
why we Believers will stand before the
Judgment because we're saved we belong
to him we pass the test we show remain
faithful and by his Mercy he ushers in
US ushers Us in so now you go to 1
Corinthians 31:15 when Ed has a chance
so bring up this for you to see go ahead
read 1 Corinthians
31:15 for no one can lay a foundation
other than which is laid which is Christ
Jesus Christ now if anyone Builds on the
foundation with gold silver precious
stones wood Hast each one's work will
become manifest manifest for the day
will disclose it because it will be
revealed by fire and the fire will test
what sort of work each one has done if
the work that anyone has built on the
foundation survives he will receive a
reward if anyone's work is burned up he
will suffer loss though he himself will
be saved but not only as Through Fire
did you catch it so why do Believers
stand before God in judgment to
determine the quality of works
right if your work was solid and
pleasing it's gold and silver so goes
through the fire purified you get a
reward but if your work was unpleasing
and was
contaminated corrupted tainted by your
evil motives then it's like H St will be
burned up so you'll lose a reward but
you will still be saved as going through
fire